yo mr. Oh baby sister I keep secret oh
it's your book
well it's so beautiful I've never read
anything like it it says who is this kid
my avatar I was just in such a dark
place states the ROI entered my body
you just started telling me story after
story and I just load everything down
and turns it into a New York Times
best-selling book can you imagine the
thing he lieth States boy JT actually
isn't feeling well he won't be joining
us after all this is like the fourth
time was this some sort of hoax I asked
you if I could take a picture of you as
him what do you mean I don't really look
anything like the kid on the book don't
you think people would notice that no no
no when you're meeting someone new would
you ever question who they say they are
birthday tea beautiful I can't do it
yeah I think he's done I'm gonna shot
one role you don't know what fortunate
you want to get the shot I almost puked
and I want it it's so much teeth a
Hollywood producer wants to make the
book into a movie I think this is too
big an opportunity
you're here at last
yeah so sorry to bother you I just
wanted to tell you how much your work
means to me
I was on the streets for Omaha to super
real for some people you know we should
stop I was that kid
it's real jakey please tell me tell me
that you wrote this book and you are
gonna say JT's whoever you wanted to be
we are given this persona and then we
are giving this body we can be in the
misery of trying to get them to match up
then we can create more it feels like
I'm making something like a performance
I mean I've ended up feeling forever
just remember just because you played a
rider definitely new one
[Music]
you